i think you made some very valid points
there and i want to add to something
very important right
and this is i think one of the biggest
challenges in in this state in
particular
with the muslim community and i have to
address it head-on uh obviously we have
the same challenge in the uk but i
believe that we have better mechanisms
of dealing with it there i'm not trying
to
you know but i think that we have a you
know more established community in the
uk only because
we've been there for much longer and
we've been able to establish ourselves
and our population is much
uh more concentrated um and we have much
less apostasy rates than in the united
states
however having said that to answer your
question directly i think
um the question of the first and
foremost about homosexuality and islam
yeah and lgbt activism and how does it
how do we deal with that because
obviously from an islamic perspective we
know that homosexuality
not from an inclination perspective from
a tendency perspective from a feeling
perspective
but certainly from an action perspective
is something which is an aberration
irreligious
against our religion we can't we're not
going to change that part of our
religion
and in fact one of the major sins of
islam so
we're i feel like this and you can
correct me if i'm wrong obviously this
is your state and you've been living
here
but i feel like there's a there's a
there's a pressure
to capitulate to this idea that actually
we should say
that the act itself i'm not talking
about the feeling and i'm not talking
about the person
homosexuals i'm not talking about the
feeling how they feel
i'm talking about homosexual sex to be
completely honest with you right
penetration yeah sorry to be another
kids in the room i'm talking about that
we are under pressure to say that's
legitimate
and it's it's moral it's it's fine but i
say
and this wallahi if there's anything
you're going to leave with today make
this be the thing that you live with
yeah because it's something that
hopefully will protect your community
and our communities everywhere this is
against every approach
let me stand up for this okay no
it's against every single approach let
me tell you why
we talked about the intersectional
approach what if someone
who feels gay also believes
that that homosexuality is a sin what if
they have two things that they're doing
at one time they feel homosexual
they feel like they're having homosexual
inclination but they also have
the belief that what if they if they act
upon that impetus
that what they will do is they'll do
something sinful
so on an intersection analysis now we
have to go back and ask
what do we prioritize in analysis what
they believe
or what they feel and if that person
makes a conscientious decision to say
you know what
i feel like this but my identity as a
human being
is should be prioritized in this way for
example in a religious way
and therefore i'm going to suppress my
sexual you know
homosexuality for example i'm going to
suppress it
then that is as legitimate on an
intersectional analysis
and the liberal analysis as someone
quote-unquote coming out of the closet
basically there is a presupposition
that sexual expressionism
should be prioritized over and above rip
um suppression
but that that doesn't make any sense why
is that the case can that be proven
so in other words there's this idea
which actually takes all the way it
takes us all the way back to freud one
guy called freud yeah
sigmund freud he wrote a book called
civilization and his discontent
and in it he basically argued and he had
this thing called the oedipus complex i
don't want to go into
major detail but he said that you know
when when when a child is born
they have psychosexual stages of
development and at one stage like for
example a young boy
feels attraction for his mother like he
wants to engage sexually with his mother
right and then we start you know
controlling those desires and so on
and he argues in his book that basically
we should be able to express
ourselves as much as possible and this
is incorporated into this liberal ethic
this liberal ethic of just do it kind of
like you know the nike slogan yeah just
do it
you know yolo live once and so on so
sexual expressionism is prioritized over
and above sexual
uh repressionism if you like so coming
out of the closet
is seen as the epitome of
a self-expression yes even though
as i made the point in my debate
yesterday for those who were there
coming out of the incest closet it was
not seen the same way yanni someone who
has sexual inclusion for their
brother or sister sorry to be very
explicit here but this is a very
important topic
because the truth is this on social
liberalism
the qaeda or the the principle is you
can do whatever you want so long as you
don't harm anyone else
that's what they say yeah do whatever
you want so long as you don't have
anyone else okay so therefore the
homosexual has the right to have sex
with
another man but a brother doesn't have
uh the right
to have uh sexual intercourse with his
sister sorry to be yani
well because deformed babies will come
about okay contraception
the same logic applies why is there lgbt
rights in this country and not incest
rights
when both of them are predicated on the
same social construct
idea of a harm principle so the idea is
that a sexual expressionism should be
prioritized
over and above a repressionism but even
in certain contexts there will be
exceptions that are made
like incest for example some taboo
things that they have society still
haven't has a
civil rights movement yet for if there
was if there was a you know a hundred
thousand
people that had sexual feelings for
their sisters and their brothers and
they come hand in hand in the streets
and they say look give us our rights
maybe things will change but why should
it be the case that that should be
what has to happen in order for society
to accept them
right you know they have the same they
should have the same rights to sexually
explain
anyway that's a different question the
point is as muslims we say all of these
things
are go back to our expression as muslims
we say as muslims our morality is
defined by what quran
and through them with that heaven so on
yeah so if we believe that having sex
with a man
if you're a man is a sexual aberration
is irreligious is wrong
and you say no that's an illegitimate
belief then you're stopping us from
believing what we want to believe
where's the freedom of expression in
that we're not gonna we are not going to
sacrifice our expression
to satisfy your own expression
don't ever allow that to happen to your
community you have to fight tooth and
nail
before that ever happens in this
community don't let them win the
argument well
even on their principles there's no way
you can lose this argument
you should be allowed to believe that
having sex two men having sex with each
other
is a moral aberration is irreligious is
not correct it's never going to be
correct
in my eyes that doesn't mean now that
i'm going to be disrespectful to
homosexuals
no we're going to have a good
relationship with homosexuals because
allah
we haven't sent you except for uh as for
all of the people for all of the people
not just for
you know one sexuality there's no
discrimination well the prophet came for
everyone the homosexual the heterosexual
the bisexual
the black man the white man the green
man the yellow man everyone
he wasn't sent for specific people which
goes back to the racist point
racism point you amen and allah
or for a black man over a white man or a
white man so it's an
inclusive message of islam but that
should not mean
that we're going to change our morality
because now you're impinging on our
freedom of expression
and you're impinging on our freedom of
thought you're telling us what to
believe
you're telling us what to believe it's
the equivalent it's the moral equivalent
of someone who's a vegetarian who
believes that eating meat is wrong
yeah is told no you can't have that
belief because we have this you know
all these people are eating meat
therefore you know all
you're calling them immoral even if they
they believe that that is an immoral
action
and eating meat is wrong shouldn't they
be allowed to
believe right that eating meat is an
immoral action is vegetarianism going to
be outlawed
are you going to call it vegephobia
you're a vegetable
no no don't don't go there the lgbt
community
they have to know full well
and you have to make this case very
clearly
that we will definitely treat you with
respect
and definitely allow you to enter our
spaces they're more welcomed in
our spaces than we are welcome in our
spaces because we want them to come into
the mosques
we want the lg we want homosexuals to
come to the mosque from uh from
from muslim faith and non-muslim faith
and yeah it's not an impossibility to be
a muslim homosexual you can have those
feelings and you can even commit the
action we're not even going to
excommunicate you from islam
even if you have sex with a thousand men
we're not going to excommunicate you
from islam
sorry to say i'm but however we are
going to say that action is wrong
and if you are and if we are stopped
from doing this
because of this what's referred to as a
homo nationalist agenda
yes where homosexuals juxtapose
themselves away from the
muslims in order to find some homes
nation state in the western world and so
on
forget about it we're not going to
accept that muslim communities have to
be strong
just like jewish communities were just
like orthodox jewish communities were
just like christian communities in the
bible belt can say ridiculous things
you're going to hell you know shut up
be quiet redneck
donald trump and these guys be quiet
and they're allowed to do that anyhow i
got a gun here and they're walking
around with guns and
threatening behavior and they're okay
but us muslims we have to be victimized
otherwise
objected for homosexuals to
no we believe firmly
wholeheartedly definitely blatantly
obviously willingly that homosexuality
if done in practice is sinful and we
will never back down from that
don't ever let you don't ever let them
back down from that position
the moment you back down from that
position will allah you back down from
islam